mais
radiohead a commencé son concert dans le
noir mais rapidement la lumière fut
[Musique]
pendant près de 2h30 radiohead a envoûté
les quinze mille fidèles réunis pour
cette célébration musicale hors du
commun
[Musique]
en pleine possession de ses moyens le
chanteur thom yorke a fait des envolées
lyriques la nantes pour un public qui
applaudissait à tout rompre
sur scène deux batteries pour créer une
section rythmique efficace établissant
un climat de france
reggie wayne a été audacieux en écartant
plusieurs grands succès sur 25 chansons
interprétées 17 étaient tirés des quatre
derniers albums et pas nécessairement
les plus connus peu importe la magie
opérait tout de même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors de ce concert pour initier il ya
bien sûr eu quelques succès de syrie du
mythique album
ok computer en rappel on a eu droit à
karma police
un internaute a mis en ligne la
magnifique chanson de touristes
[Musique]
réduire est dans une musique planante
parfois expérimental on aime ou on
n'aime pas des spectateurs pour beaucoup
aimé son expérience dans vos talons il
sera aujourd'hui que de très bons tant
que fan finie je te mécontents sont
extraordinaires c'est toujours il ya des
chansons qui font toujours qu'il y avait
toujours des surprises réduite sera à
nouveau en concert à montréal ce soir et
à toronto jeudi et vendredi
ici louis philippe ouimet radio-canada
m'ont rien
[Musique]